E aí
é o que o tempo vai dizer sobre você o
que vimos no passado recente nos permite
refletir sobre um novo tempo este que
pode ser de repetição de erros
históricos como descaso com o meio
ambiente a violência contra pessoas
específicas e também uma série de
descaso quando tiver diferente realidade
ou a construção de um novo amanhã mais
potente de direitos e cuidados com a
lugar eu quero esse outro e vocês
qualquer lugar de onde eu venho a favela
Primeiro me ensinou sobre vida depois
ela me salvou e hoje eu caminho para
mostrar que a favela local de potência
cultural história a criatividade Brasil
e no meu lugar encontramos pessoas que
são descendentes de indígenas
quilombolas as pessoas do norte do
nordeste brasileiro ou seja toda aquela
grande potência significativa do Brasil
na sua mais pura raiz mas que porém
passam pela tentativa Histórica de
silenciamento não investimento a
pagamento e nesse contexto infelizmente
a nossa sobrevivência acaba virando reta
comecei a trabalhar aqui na favela mesmo
ajudando pessoas idosas a levarem e suas
compras Complexo do Alemão acima
complexo alemão ao lugar que eu vivo no
Rio de Janeiro uma favela que cresce
para o alto do morro por volta de 11
anos eu comecei a trabalhar na feira
isso me fez conhecer muito mais no lugar
no as histórias daqui e principalmente
perder a vergonha de falar em público
porque eu tinha que ficar ali no pé do
morro na feira oferecendo ajuda para as
pessoas isso me fez ficar mais solto na
fala com menos vergonha de me expor
e ir além disso não aprendi nesse
Convívio com as pessoas mais idosas
sobre como surgiu a favela exatamente
Quem eram as pessoas mais ativas daqui e
me tornei um grande conhecedor dos becos
e fiáveis desse lugar onde a vida pulsa
na coletividade tornando cada Beco e
Viela da favela único aliás galera isso
vale para o Brasil inteiro nenhuma
favela é igual cada uma e cada Beco e
Viela tem sua riqueza em particular a
primeira vez que eu fui procurar um
emprego fora da favela eu fui totalmente
humilhado quando dei o endereço do lugar
onde ao vivo e obviamente não tive a
vaga então eu fiquei refletindo sobre
como falar de onde eu sou ser de onde eu
sou naquele período fechava portas eu
não quis aceitar isso ou então que eu
comecei uma caminhada de aprender
coletivo né aqui na própria favela com
as pessoas daqui sobre Qual é a
importância Quais são os significados
desse lugar
o que essas existentes e porque somos
vistos dessa forma negativa da favela
para fora e nesse processo na
desigualdade de tentar sobreviver e
conseguir avançar na vida de antes
exatamente da sociedade que impõe essa
leitura desigual sobre nós sobre o lugar
tornar-se isso gerou muita desigualdade
muita dificuldade no meu caminhar então
é importante Lembrar para para todas as
pessoas que o seu falar sem pensar o seu
acompanhar sem conhecer alimentam
questões históricas terríveis racismo
desigualdade violência direcionada
enquanto a sociedade a contar as favelas
e construir estereótipos nós
dificilmente avançaremos para um novo
Brasil no Brasil melhor diferente
infelizmente desse que ainda temos hoje
participei da construção do coletivo
papo reto aqui mesmo no Complexo do
Alemão e trabalho com educação cultura
comunicação e
de dentro da favela disputando uma outra
narrativa sobre o significado da favela
e sobre a sua importância a partir da
Juventude local e também participei da
formação do coletivo movimentos um
coletivo de jovens de favelas e
periferias discutindo uma outra política
de drogas já que essa muitas vezes é a
única política pública padrão para
dentro desse espaço a partir de uma
ideia de guerra às drogas e cria
estereótipos e mantém uma série de
estruturas de racismo históricas até
hoje nesse processo recentemente também
fundei o favela e o DS para discutir os
objetivos globais para o desenvolvimento
sustentável a partir da própria favela e
com a favela temas importantíssimos que
nós devemos discutir ainda mais nesse
durante pode fazer minha Global porque
muitas vezes não falamos sobre questões
ainda são simples
a observar a favela né me mostra que
aqui no lugar onde eu vivo é de onde
saem as estratégias tecnológicos e
transformaram o planeta porque não se
trata apenas da criatividade pulsante
mas de ser criativo e tentar seguir onde
a sobrevivência é regra os grandes
problemas do mundo ainda são os mesmos
exploração desenfreada do planeta a seus
recursos naturais né as crises Lima o
racismo a fome a exploração capitalista
a violência direcionada às pessoas mais
pobres e Nossa gente vocês podemos
Juntas e juntos mudar essa realidade eu
falo isso para dizer que o seu caminhar
pode transformar a coletividade com a
melhor o poderia ter saído da favela
deixar para lá seguir o meu caminho mas
eu quero impactar positivamente a cidade
Ah pois não existe mérito em realidade
estão desiguais se uma pessoa foge à
regra imposta não é mérito é exceção e
eu não caminho por oportunidade para um
mas para a construção de perspectiva
para todas as pessoas Principalmente as
pessoas que vem do lugar onde ao vivo a
favela tão estereotipada Vista com tanto
preconceito é uma das clientes soluções
para transformar nos sim positivamente o
mundo e diante dessa situação global de
pandemia que vivemos Infelizmente o Nós
por Nós mais uma vez foi Central para
favela e ficou abandonada sozinha e
ignorada e onde se aproximaram numa
velocidade muito rápida as desigualdades
que a gente historicamente já conhece a
fome a sede a falta de informações
precisas o abandono do Poder Como regra
isso nos fez nos organizarmos pela nossa
própria sobrevivência usando de novo a
coletividade orgânica como estratégia
em salvar essas vidas Ou seja a favela é
potência ela tem a capacidade de
construir soluções pras suas demandas
esse exemplo de dentro para fora
possibilidade de impacto transformador
na realidade local e na localidade
Global Global uma bandeira Global a
razão mundo tirava muitas vidas e com
isso nós no desacelerar de quem
sobreviveu temos a possibilidade de
reorganizar o nosso tempo para o novo
tempo é possível se olhar para o lado e
ajudar outras pessoas diminuir essa
correria diminuir o força EA velocidade
da geração tecnológica que tipo funciona
pra frente e observar para os lados ver
que dá para você desburocratizar de
ferramentas de Jesus para ajudar outras
pessoas o meio ambiente o planeta as
pessoas é possível sim fazer algo e
avançar em questão de paradas furanos e
podem acabar com as programadas
Oi gente tá atenção nesse momento para
onde você está direcionando o seu tempo
a construção de um novo amanhã mais
potente de Direito de cuidados ou
humanidade com o planeta é o meu agir
Quem foi você no tempo de escolhas você
fez qual legado vai deixar ele está
correndo muitas vezes desigual e brutal
a partir da cor da pele ou classe social
enquanto tem gente querendo voltar ao
normal pessoas que vivem Onde eu vivo
não querem um novo de ao passado seja
igual e ele passará rápido então me diga
a você o que será que as narrativas
históricas do passado contaria sobre
você ele tá passando ele passa rápido e
se você agora tivesse um momento para
com suas palavras contar mas só a
verdade pudesse dizer o que o nosso
agora saberia sobre você sim e passa
rápido Ninguém é igual eu sei
é mas posso dizer que eu tentei em
relação ao todo não ignorei ele está
correndo nesse momento um novo tempo que
já se torna passado e surge um novo que
passa também um ciclo que parece sem sim
enfim mas para nós tem fim e nesse tempo
que você teve o que você fez e se me
permite mais um segundo do seu tempo não
deixa que eu te falo se tornem apenas
palavras ao vento ou passadas no tempo
por isso eu não quero voltar ao normal
nem um novo normal eu quero apenas um
novo e Podemos construir juntos juntos
eu acredito é possível a pausa e a
desaceleração do mundo nos mostrou que é
possível nos observavam melhor ou mais
cuidado mais atenção é nisso que eu
acredito esse mais uma pessoa aqui
acreditar comigo já não haverá
é tão nessa caminhada então nós podemos
construir um novo a desaceleração é a
oportunidade para construção de
perspectiva e redução das desigualdades
muito menos perdas de história de
potências dívidas e de tempo obrigado é
isso